i had this dream that i was floating
i had this dream that i was on top of
the tallest
building and i could see everything
around me now
and i crept my toes over the edge i had
to see that i was floating
i had the dream that i was on top cut my
toes over the
edge and i dropped everything
i was holding
i'm tearing down all these outmoded
ideas about now
how it's going what it is and how it
sounds and i walk like midnight
sitting here my grip light won't let it
slip till i get light
i'm burning all these old bodies holding
no
signal no comb in the ash that the
breeze sorted out
poured it out that house i tore it down
when it all boils down there's nothing
but bones left
but bones left nothing but bones left
nothing and it's the same safe but the
codes won't work
guess the joke's on me looks like i'm on
first the map got hurt
or the river took out the bridge but we
can't get out the way that we came
in the compass needle is sticking the
numbers step out of sequence the stars
here look hard they like the ones from
last season
and we've been leaking diesel since the
first freeze you can leave the car keys
in it i'm getting out
each brick is a pixel each step is the
stitch in the dust grass little whistle
buzzed
by the breath in your lungs get your day
in the sun to be young